[Music]
it's me already everyone already he's
popped in what are you gonna stay a
teens here okay cool
yes it is your favorite thing to do okay
Neil's gonna come back me already yeah
Lana favorite me already everyone anyway
um oh and that's what that waters for
you that's a gift that's our hop hop
breath water serve response how could I
even drink it I would like to save it
the coolest water for the hottest
podcast I love it um so yeah anyway
we're going into storytelling in the
struggle and uh something I when
researching you I heard you say is that
you'll improvise but have like safety
nets yeah yeah long the way absolutely
what is how do you um how do you kind of
incorporate those into this writing
process you know I guess there are some
comics out there that like have jokes
that like maybe or 50% and so they're
saves actually end up becoming the funny
part you know I mean I'm not even like
specifically thinking of someone but
there's comics like that which can also
be its own thing which is fun but the
safety nuts I would say it's almost like
totems within the set like especially
right now it's been almost two years I
guess since I recorded in my half hour
and it came out and so I'm got my new
hour like pretty much pretty close and
so I have basically a framework you know
just like um I guess whatever the
defense posts that I know I need to hit
and I'm still figuring out and I'd like
to add tags and make it better and
callbacks and so I basically now have
chosen an order that is sort of like my
my my fence posts along the way okay and
then I can play within them you know so
if something doesn't go well it's like
well I know I have a good joke coming
but I always tried something it almost
gives you the confidence to explore on
stage because you know you have yeah
save it if it's silent for too long yeah
absolutely
and I guess just in general I like to
have a lot of laugh lines I mean I know
that seems pretty obvious but ideally
you have I I don't like to go that long
with without having a laugh line yeah
yeah I mean I think that's pretty good
you know speaks for itself
like most comedy most comedians want to
get laughs with some engines we'll call
it they like style like yeah it's not
really funny but it's like cool or
whatever funny just dark and not exactly
funny yet you know and sometimes still
if people don't get me wrong I didn't
get my style there'll be times where it
can it happens less rare but like even
tonight there was a woman in the front
row who you could tell was probably
meant to be there but I think was during
one joke where she was like oh which you
know of course like to me is cringe like
that's the last thing I want to hear
that's not the reason I'm telling you
this you know ideally the joke is to
make you laugh about something that was
not great you know so when they take it
the wrong way or too sensitive for you
it's like no that's not what I wanted
you know and so I think for the longest
time it really was more dark and not not
funny enough and so I've tried to master
that as the years go on being able to
make it funny enough but also dark do
you almost find though how you're saying
the dark thing can affect the reaction
of it absolutely yeah because I almost
get annoyed with like if I'm not if I'm
not enthusiastic and I say a joke that
usually works then it won't work yeah
it's almost like how you're saying it is
almost as important as what you're
saying yeah absolutely you know I think
so too
I assume timers will play with it
especially if I'm oddly I've been
dealing with this weird thing lately
where sometimes like I'm having trouble
catching my breath on stage which
actually has never really happened to me
and I'm sort of I begin to wonder I'm
like is it allergy am I getting older
and I am having allergies or something
in the certain places that I'm traveling
to I can't totally figure it out but
like I am fine with being slow but I
think as the years go on my pacing has
gotten quicker I guess I mean I've
Changez atomic since I've started right
um I think maybe more to myself I feel
very different than maybe to an onlooker
but even if you watch like my first
conan set from whatever it is six years
ago I obviously think I'm very different
from from then oh yeah but I it's one of
those things where you just don't
realize like obviously it's a human
you're gonna change and then it goes
with your comedy as well so I feel like
the way I'm saying things now is maybe
more closer to my personality as opposed
to how I started which was more deadpan
and so sometimes when I go deadpan cuz
I'm tired or if I can't try oh you also
get some background chatter laughing
laughing school greenroom yeah that's
where we are it was because of me that
we're in here Hillar thanks for coming
that's what the main thing I was so
curious about diving into was the
writing side because you have the
stand-up experience but then also I mean
the TV writing and yeah writing for so
many series that's a world that I
haven't I don't have much experience
with but the people I've talked to they
almost make it seem like I mean it's
cool you're a writer but they're like
but you work you're like they're you're
like all day yeah and it definitely will
affect your standup of course yeah
they're all day it's tough to want to
get up at night and really you're sort
of brain is fried by the end of the day
you sort of have what I've talked about
with other comics just like decision
fatigue you know as you sit in the room
you're deciding whether to talk or that
it or not talk you know what joke to
pitch whether it's good and if you're
doing a lot of like mental work I mean
it seems so silly because essentially so
many people want to write for TV and it
it is a coveted job so than to get there
and be like I'm tired or complain it
feels crazy you know so you don't want
to be like man my writing job is tough
because it really is a coveted position
and it is an honor to be able to work
and you know do all those things and of
course I'm I you know you work hard for
them but the point is it is exhausting
you know sit
at a computer is it tough on your eyes
and yeah so it's just like it seems like
such a stupid thing to complain about
but you kinda have to take care of
yourself relax rest your eyes get good
sleep cuz it's your main job and
thankfully stand-up is always kind of
there and I can go back to it but I
usually start like when I was running on
crashing in New York we would move there
and continue the writing process from LA
for about a month and then we would
shoot for two or three months okay and
so um I would be there and I would do a
lot of sets initially and then as time
wears on our shoot days are twelve hours
and so sometimes if we were shooting
over by the seller or village
underground it's like I could pop over
and sneak away but you also don't want
to get caught like can I get alts for
this and like where's Beth you know they
made it as like she's on stage so the
benefit was being close you just hop on
a train in New York but also you kind of
would have to ask permission to leave
and because this shows about stand-up
the beauty of that was often times they
were very lenient you know they could
say yeah I'll do it
because you might get a story out of it
or perspective or something to add to
the show and what our alts like
alternative jokes to what was written in
the script okay yeah cool yeah so
basically or like similarly to if you're
doing punch up you know on a movie or
something it'll be like it's written but
can we beat it you know on the spot or
if they improvise something can you add
to it or and you'll have or if the
scenes not working oh then on the spot
you would go away and rewrite it
oh and just kind of spit right there
yeah oh okay interesting and then on top
of it any time typically with with Judd
there's a lot of improv that's going on
that's what I've heard yeah yeah it's
very collaborative in that seems yeah so
it might just be like sometimes he's
even just kind of yelling things out for
that for the actor I mean I'm not in an
aggressive way it's in a microphone you
know or yeah yeah yeah um but yeah sort
of like just tossing things out of there
and you went from year one on crashing
staff writer to the year - you're like
executive story editor yeah the way that
writing works typically is like your
deal is sort of worked out when you were
brought on you know so in your deal your
agents have worked out if she if you
bring her back for season two
you know receive a higher credit and if
I went further on I would have increased
each time you know that's kind of like
the the set up of the whole gig
essentially your agents are supposed to
sort of look out for you in that way but
yeah I did not go back for season 3 I
took some other writing opportunities
and well you know I kind of wanted to go
in different directions so it gave me
experience and writing for like hilarity
for charity Seth Rogen's Netflix special
and us pilot for David Spade for Comedy
Central and and then punch up on that
movie this summer in Vancouver that'll
be out this July it's called good boys
so I got to really I really got to
bounce around and try several different
things as opposed to just TV writing
which I am grateful I learned a lot you
know from from crashing and from Jud and
being on that show yeah what did you
learn like basically when I first got
the job of course it was life changing I
remember where I was I was just like
outside this bike shop I just done this
meeting and um you take a lot of
meetings in LA typically especially when
you're first going you're just sort of
trying to get your face out there and
meet people who you might click with and
work with in the future or whatever but
electric something I think it's jack
black's company and i came downstairs
and i was like near this bike shop and i
got the call and my managers were just
like um hey judd apatow just called and
asked if you wanted to write for
crashing and I was like yes yeah I do
and I just remember like this is
incredible you know like my life will
change because of this because it's very
difficult to get a writing job and you
know I had done a couple jawed at that
time he had seen me out a lot cuz he was
starting to get back into stand-up and
so as you we saw his special came out
last Christmas time that's what he was
working towards but like that's why his
reinvestment in stand-up and in Pete's
show and all that inspired him to start
doing stand-up again I'm sure among
other things but from my viewpoint in
talking with him so he saw him he was
out on the scene getting back into it
and he saw me and I had been on the Pete
Holmes show 9uu P and so when it came to
hiring writers they just they thought of
me and my I went into to write for it
so what does a typical day look
like on the writing job you get in you
have coffee one time usually around 9:00
okay yeah reasonable yes sometimes we
would start early and then you already
start thinking about lunch it's a lot of
ordering food it's a lot of ordering
food and coffee but yeah I mean the
ideal early processes are what what the
early stages I should say are like oh
what they would call like blue sky so
you're just sort of pitching things out
in a sort of brainstorming way sharing
stories and stuff where where the show
could go you know from your own life and
you know just commiserating but also
sharing group experience and a lot of us
have been to the same comedy clubs and
so we know the owners we sure are
different stories about that there you
know and all the things that could
happen and there there's a writer's
assistant in the room who usually that
person is wants to be a writer and they
work extremely hard and they're paid the
least and you know they do a lot of work
because they're organizing everybody's
thoughts and taking them down in real
time
yes writers assistant is a very very
tough job
I think there's somewhat hard to get and
like I said they worked so hard and
they're paid the least and so they're
they're taking everything down and then
those notes will go out and you can you
know review them over the you know
overnight if you wanted the next day
come in and as weeks go on in the early
stages you're sort of trying to map out
the season you know episodes whatever
how many episodes your show is but for
us one through eight and sort of the arc
of the season and the characters and all
of those things they start to take form
as the week's go on and we sort of lock
things in and Judd would pop he's not
there every single day but he sort of
pop in sorry it's so loud no you're okay
these mics will pick up man oh good good
okay yeah this is calm this is the grind
right here I know but Judd would sort of
come in and basically sort of shape or
hone in on the ideas or basically share
his expertise like here's where I think
this should go and sometimes we'd be
going off on a tangent for a long time
and if he didn't pop in for awhile he
could come in and be like no he would
never be like
No you know he's not like that he would
just be like what if it goes in this
direction or I think the series isn't
like for season one I remember he's like
what if it ends with leaf and Pete and
Abed together and then so we would have
to sort of find our way to that even if
even if that's not where we were going
at all thing so yeah he's I mean he's
the executive producer so he has pretty
much the final set most like one of
those tent poles though yeah like you
said like with your stand-up you like
here's where we need to get oh yeah
the destination yeah he want he had a
vision for how we wanted the season to
end and how we were gonna get there was
our the task and how many hours a day is
this usually it depends on your
showrunner like their style and you know
sometimes if they feel like well you're
exhausted we've exhausted our minds
today you can go home hmm it depends but
you know there are shows I know for a
fact I hear these stories about like oh
the new girl room was really long they
would be there sometimes overnight you
know her stayed till 11:00 or midnight
and with crashing it was typically like
9:00 or 10:00 2:00 to 6:00 ish you know
something like that so like decent hours
sometimes early or sometimes later I've
heard Pete say in interviews with
crashing specifically in writing it that
uh he felt like if what they were
talking about didn't make him
uncomfortable or didn't feel too
personal to share then almost wasn't
worth keeping mm-hmm do you find the
same with your material or things that
you write as well or did you find that
in the show or yeah I mean I think it's
like you your desire obviously is to
connect with mind desires to connect
with people first and foremost but in my
own very unique way and so I mean I'm
not calling myself very unique but I'm
saying
ideally I'm connecting with them in a
unique way you know I don't I don't want
it to be
I like the specificity of things you
know and so my favorite things early on
and stand-up were when I would see a
comic talking about something very very
specific and me knowing exactly what
they were talking about it just made me
laugh so hard and that was my favorite
thing about it it's like how could they
and those are the moments we were like
man I wish
I thought of that those those times
where you see jokes that you're
basically jealous of because you're like
that's so good why didn't I
so really all you're trying to do is
just get that unique perspective on
topics that really a lot of people can
relate to you know and then again not
everyone is going to like you and I
think that's probably a good thing in my
opinion it hurts a little because a lot
of us are you know either star for
attention or we're in this for a reason
because we need that like sort of love
from the outside so it can hurt a little
if not everybody likes what you do but I
think in general it's probably I would
prefer having a specific group of people
than everyone do you think that's helped
you to find your voice as well like you
say yeah right I don't like I guess I
maybe I would be fooling myself to say
that I don't love creating some tension
you know I think I do I think too for a
long time it was one of those things
where it's like you just you wanna you
don't want to stir things up or whatever
or have like a super strong opinion
because because you want to be liked and
that was obviously a theme for me as a
kid as like a little performer an
attention seeker like I wanted to be
liked and obviously I still have that in
me as a stand-up you know I enjoy
getting laughs but now I think I have
more of a desire to say what's on my
mind or or or make a sort of statement
or a point or share my perspective on it
you know yeah and maybe open up somebody
else's mind to it yeah so I don't
necessarily want to be like you know I'm
a super political comic I'm not or at
least I don't I mean I don't see myself
that way but I would like to shake open
up somebody's eyes to a different
perspective it seems like the power with
walking that line is like in the writing
and how you kind of navigate those
waters mm-hmm so yeah when you're
developing stand-up what is what is that
process I've heard you say it sometimes
it's papers on a table sometimes it's
like out cards or sticky notes on the
wall yeah I usually don't like a one you
know I
I used to when I first started to write
out jokes you know word for word
verbatim okay yeah type them in my
computer I don't do that anymore mostly
because it's just they seem to disappear
in my computer in my notes I have a ton
of ideas and I'll have to go through
them sometimes and then they're
everywhere they're they're paper they're
in my notes on my phone and sometimes I
have to go through and like I'll
summarize them into a group in my
notebook and be like these are all new
ideas you should go through I mean I've
tried to adapt this mantra in my head
where if I have a day off or whatever or
many days off where I don't really have
a show or a headlining weekend or
something I'm like there's always work
to be done yeah and I sometimes I'm just
like I don't have anything to do but
there's so much work that can be done on
stand-up for you to be really good and
it's easier to just get by with a joke
that works and to make it perfect and
then again of course there's you can do
that too much you know you don't want to
be a perfectionist and never you know
finish a joke or make it too perfect you
know there's obviously a middle ground
and balance on anything but um now I
sort of do one word or sometimes I'll
take a voice memo that's usually an idea
in my head and I just have to try it on
stage and at this point I've grown
comfortable enough on stage that I find
it a luxury to just be able to you know
try jokes within a headlining set which
of course hasn't always been the case
you sometimes have to show up and just
really deliver because you're not is
known or you don't know if you'll be
invited back you know as an early
headliner so you can't just like try
[ __ ] down throw it against the wall but
I don't I do that now which I'm I have
fun with you know like I said I can just
like play between things but um it's
usually a one word on a note card for a
joke and an order that I have going on
my wall it's hard to be what's it called
um subjective of your own things you
know it's not the word I always get
objective and subjective confuse
subjective specific object yes
subjective is like is seeking out the
content yes so it's hard to be objective
about your act so you're like saying you
see I ran a friend and it's hard I don't
know if I was was I really hunching over
here in this video the whole time Oh
I don't know this is definitely green
room so right now the lighting is a
little spit down light is just giving us
my shadows but anyway you get tight you
get in your own head about your material
well it's hard to just say like yeah I
mean that's why it's helpful when you
have someone you trust to watch and say
like whatever say you had a joke on
hoodies or something you talk everything
about I'm just saying because we're both
wearing them yeah you know and you talk
about the color and you talk about the
zipper you talk about everything I'm
like dude what about the strings and you
go whoa
obviously it's so simple but you just
needed somebody else on the outside you
Blake you're not even talking about the
strings and then I call thinking of that
so it's like sometimes you take somebody
else's creative mind to see a different
angle on it that you just for whatever
reason cannot see yeah and I don't I was
a lone wolf for a really long time so I
think I have the TV writing stuff to
thank for making me be more
collaborative but yeah I mean stand-up
there's a pride in the fact that you do
it alone
and I you know I write all my own jokes
and there are all true stories from my
life and so I think that's probably a
parent although some people have been
like it's not real you know and I'm like
yeah it's strange but it's it's real my
life my childhood so um but now I'm more
open to at least someone saying what if
you you know like I asked you never want
to really like go up to a comic and be
like here's my notes you know you want
to go with somebody you trust and
specifically ask them but they can help
you sort of see something you might not
see you know like I've just been toying
I mean I'm in the South right now but
I've been toying with moving some things
around in my set that are more
progressive but the truth is if I film
or you know tape my next special and
keep it at the top where I would like it
to be where I'll do it it will be
ideally grouping of my fans and they'll
be more on the progressive side and so
it will be received well so there's a
lot of factors that go into stand-up you
know where you are you know whether or
not the people that have come out to see
you are already fans or if they just
came to see a comedy show mm-hmm you
know there's a lot of factors something
that's tough for comedians is to know
like when when to just let go of the
joke
how many times will you try a joke
before like okay I tried in this hipster
bar I tried it in the restaurant I tried
in this comedy club and like it worked
here but not here here like how do you
know when it's like all right it's dead
I know it's tough it's weird
sometimes I don't sometimes I hold on to
it for a really long time even if it
doesn't work because it works enough
times and I like it right right it's
hard it was something I learned I think
from a college professor it was like
it's called killing your babies mmm well
you just have to UM you can't keep
everything so precious you know you just
have to say I'm gonna have to let this
one go there's more it's interesting
that was the expression that he used but
anyway yeah I've heard that expression
well no like that's okay but everybody's
real pissed about abortion but anyway
yeah it's just cool you you're you're
able to hide great writing with a casual
delivery
well we have four minutes wait for me
sweet Beth wants the desert
that's arrived
I know but you lost a tooth first I saw
your modern comedian oh yeah I'm missing
one of my sugar sugar teeth is missing
I'm getting an implant on Monday I can
blend see oh so you're gonna have it for
the special and all that
I won't I think it takes like six months
oh I don't really have a date right now
that I've set for recording it anyway so
I just but going back to that it's
almost like that's another thing it's
like when when you record it then that's
your end time I mean obviously you can
still tell jokes that you like from that
I think the idea of killing everything
you've ever written you know it's not
great but when you're ready to occur it
an hour you're typically building to
weed out all old things
whereas in between specials you can have
fun mixing from old if you want cuz
people come out to see you that like
your old stuff and if you want I like to
mix things in but I can't really do that
right now because I need to get in the
practice of doing all the new stuff that
being said I still gravitate or towards
certain subjects or what am I trying to
say sort of hover around sort of certain
topics that I just always kind of talk
about you know so it there's similar
joke areas but different new jokes yeah
and you're better you're better at
writing and inserting your point of view
yeah post maybe your first Conan set
like you say right yeah I mean which is
a great set well thanks yeah I think I
don't it's not I don't want to be the
person that looks back and like hates
all my old stuff but it is tough to love
it because you have changed and you like
to think that you're better and I think
that comedy people love to go so hard on
things you know like with their opinion
whether it's good or it's not good and I
get the nature of that I do but it's
just I'm actually it is fun and I'm
thankful to have those older things
online coat into what I have now just
because it's like yeah people change of
course
well it's interesting our country in a
lot of ways is so obsessed with change
or not change I mean once I'm not
political but this just comes to my as a
comic I'm a political person and care
about politics and I vote and but the
point is like remember when that eye
how old you are but it was like John
Kerry essentially lost an election based
off of the idea that they he was a
flip-flopper okay like it was like he
flip-flops on things and it's like I
hope so
you know like Hillary yeah Hillary used
to also not totally support I think gay
rights and since she's changed it's like
we're it's very odd as a country we
don't love change I get if someone is
like lying to your face and doing
something else but yeah I think change
that's just sorry I just went off on a
tangent but it's like we're oddly
obsessed with you have to stick to your
guns and it's like we should all be
trying to constantly change and grow and
so I don't know where I went off on even
thinking of in the big swings of like a
comedy career and like the highs and
lows like you record your first album
the night before your notebooks get
stolen and then you record an album and
then you get booked for Conan like as
well so yeah finding your career that
it's almost like the lower the lows
there's always a high to kind of bring
yes that has happened
absolutely and there's always there's
also yeah I mean I remember feeling
about like maybe I wanted to stop and
then I got the Chicago readers like best
comic of Chicago thing truly like the
next my friend was like look okay pick
up a Chicago reader and I was like what
and you know and then like you said like
the notebooks getting stolen and then me
being at like you know forced to sort of
trust myself and my memory and of course
I looked back at the album and I don't
love it and I think like why did I put
that out there's no reason for it you
know I mean like you have these things
in your head like I have to put on our
milestones
yeah but then again going back to what I
said earlier it's like you also don't
want to never put one out mmm so there
is a balance to everything it's just and
it's and it's out there and I know some
people have enjoyed it but it's tough
for me to listen to well thanks thanks
for doing this
yeah hit the 30 minute mark and before
we get out of here you know a lot of
comedians listen to this is there
anything else you want the world to know
or like any closing advice you may have
for comedians out there yeah I mean I
think the one thing I always like to say
is just sort of like there's
like for comics you loved it wasn't
always easy you know you sort of have to
build your audience and it's like drops
in a bucket and sometimes you do things
and it's more of like a splash and but
it takes time typically of course
there's gonna be someone who like maybe
moves to LA and gets on a show that ends
up being huge and then they get to tour
you know like there's always exceptions
to the role right ideally it is sort of
a long slower process and not everybody
was laughing at their jokes at first you
know it's like you have to it just it
takes time and as long as you're staying
true to yourself and doing what you
think is funny you're probably gonna
have fun and enjoy yourself boom all
right that's telling thanks for being on
hop right yes of course thanks for
having me
[Music]
I breath